[Music]
Bart
do you know the significance of May 20th
in China is it Cinco de Mayo it's equal
to do say they always do it late mail
solely wait what's 20 in mandarin
pursued their mail is it Chinese we
[Music]
[Laughter]
apparently it is it's the equivalent of
our Valentine's Day holiday is it the
singles day no that's 11:11 yeah
November only no because it's 1:1 that's
a 4-way day yeah it's a better time I
think that the spring times is way
sexier than than [ __ ] winter yeah
still kind of cold well we needed it for
marketing so that we can get rid of a
bunch of [ __ ] true a lot of I have to
drive the economy a lot of the holidays
they are for that before you get into
that's just a you know it's a [ __ ] when
you want to break up with somebody but
it's like Thanksgiving Christmas New
Year's Valentine's uh-huh struggle I did
it anyway ruthless because you don't
wanna break up somebody right around the
holidays like you know I did it the day
before Christmas I didn't even occur to
me it was Valentine's Day with me like
on Valentine's Day you broke up with
someone well because he had Harnish yeah
he has gonna be his girlfriend the day
before and you know [ __ ] into deep
tiff couldn't say no and then I just
changed your mind on Valentine's Day so
just like because he was like this
really weird kid in school and then
people started making fun of me for be
with yeah you never liked them no I did
the weird kid she said like I'm sorry
people start making fun of me for dating
you I can't do it
oh he was like kind of like an emo ish
kid okay but like I thought he was like
you racer eater no not that kind of
weird he was more like like cute cry all
the time
he would actually like self-harm he had
like a lot of like you know just going
on an interesting hobby
I felt really bad I felt really bad that
I had like I'm sorry I'm not into
cutting myself either Valentine thing
yeah can't be with a self-harm kid yeah
I think you came off great in this dude
you know it's crazy
he's already got depression and then on
Valentine's Day let's just burn though
harder well handled - yes no I know it's
[ __ ] up oh just for the record this
kid was like dating so many girl like
every other weekend a new girl justified
it's just a few felt just like one of
his holes I was just like oh great she's
dating that guy like another girl is
dating that guy anyway anyway so years
later because this was in eighth grade
right and then when I was 20 ish I think
I was going through a really tough time
and then we were friends on Facebook and
then randomly I hit him up and I'm like
hey have you been and blah blah like
conversation and then I'm just like hey
I'm just wondering like how have you
like been like how have you dealt with
all the things that you to break up the
Valentine's Day know like if you're like
he was really like open about the fact
that he just had all these issues and
and I was just like how did you deal
with it so I'm kind of struggling just
you know wondering like you have any
advice or something and then he ended up
being really chill he was like oh yeah
that was like middle school me like
that's so not who I am whatever he
started like being really nice and gave
me advice that's the whole point
well school then you guys smashed no
that's as it was born but yeah it was
just I don't know that guy's interesting
okay anyway no regrets right if no
regrets
okay so 525 20 is Chinese equivalent
Valentine's Day right sure Adam male
alright so this woman recently caught
her boyfriend cheating on a valentine
day um like 20 before 5:20 and so
apparently she went through her
boyfriend's phone a few days before and
was shocked to see he'd been texting
other girls and had already cheated on
her okay quarantine again [ __ ] over
there
they're on their second wave Oh she
ended up like she says that she was she
was crying her heart out for three solid
days meanwhile her ex was already I mean
like moving on having the time of his
life and and he so she heard that he
didn't give a [ __ ] and oh she was just
like you know heartbroken all these days
he's a wool horn player she had red
situa tears man dose of just that you
want chilli tears too to have him suffer
as much as she did oh so what she did is
she ordered she ordered 1000 milligrams
Szechuan chili onions like what the do
man delivery guy onion boy how much does
that know right how much get he resell
them for yeah [ __ ] sit give
distributor now thank you I started the
onion business you stupid [ __ ] by the
way you don't cry unless you crack it
open she's a victim we're [ __ ]
roasted her go bag dude she [ __ ] up
she she [ __ ] up hard because there's a
lot of like collateral damage here like
in this instance because everyone in the
building has been suffering with the
stench of onions and the guy wasn't even
home but they're not even cut though how
does it smell
I mean they still smell like onion
imagine have enough onions I guess
imagine putting your nose next to an
onion and then and then many many many
many many onions if it gets rotten it's
pretty bad that's what she should have
done and she gets it cheaper come on
ladies I just like how we're way more
vindictive than her we could
he'll turn I know we could have we have
wave drama to that [ __ ] has we could
have brain Stein with you leaves like
someone that wrote an open letter it's
like who you really got it let me help
you girl yeah so what she ended up
saying and like she delivered or she had
someone deliver all these onions and the
delivery guy was like [ __ ] man if he
doesn't cry I'm gonna cry the hard work
unloading a thousand kilograms of onion
soup and he's on the fifth floor and no
elevator do you think she was doing what
she knew that the delivery that's [ __ ]
up what do think she was doing when she
knew that the delivery was gonna arrive
his front door at 12:00 we think she was
doing at home what she like it's
actually so laying around but the note
says if the note says sorry the note
says you made me cry for three days now
it's your turn
this is soli she is so dramatic
might if the movements she comes up with
his ideas he's been crying for three
nights she goes that's what I'll do I'm
gonna send him eight sus4 man yeah she
was in the middle of ordering lunch and
thinking about what she's gonna he needs
to cry as much as I'm crying right now
but how can he cause he's an emotionless
[ __ ] onions so that's how she really
thought it we could have like tied his
ass down and put this switch one stitch
one chili switch one Chili's you know
let's make really cries right thing
Mason oh yeah hire a Chinese thug to
[ __ ] pepper spray pepper yeah Sichuan
pepper spray
flashes tires windows or something do
some American [ __ ] maybe cuz all of our
things are just illegal so she's kind of
like I don't want to break the law isn't
Chinese illegal but they don't break the
law I think they know I don't think they
break the law they know how to
circumvent the law and do loopholes
take the onion money make yourself hot
as [ __ ] you know I'm saying that's
best revenge maybe he's allergic to
onions and it was like a death threat
but then that's illegal or she could
just [ __ ] his best friend doing a normal
prison yeah cheaper too well you do it
for revenge
yeah you take one for your own team all
four people work try to so we pop in
there that's honestly like what Geo
sounds like just [ __ ] move on lady
like it's fine just you're better off
trust me
I always get ahead not even because
getting ahead is much better and it
feels really good and getting ahead by
getting ahead yeah giving her her giving
that guy's best friend ahead while
getting ahead while holding onions
I do also feel like it's hard to move on
though in this time hard you know people
got [ __ ] to do yeah so if you were going
through a breakup where you usually go
back to work have a job or do whatever
hang out with your friends you can get
your mind off things for just marinating
as a [ __ ] right now cuz you're
not allowed to like just be in different
energy damn or maybe since everything
was on quarantine that's like the only
option she had she had all these dope
ideas with everything's closed
- and the pepper she's watching this
video right now like guys I have better
idea you try to be vindictive during
this time talk to you she knows onion
18th under live circus we ran on toilet
paper
yeah China they already ran out of the
peppers or whatever that yeah her first
thing was to TP his house are you doing
a shortage imagine how expensive that
would be now to TP somebody's dude I saw
some headlight or something I read the
story but it was something about one of
the Kardashian sisters tp'ing
another one and that people were like
what the [ __ ] ya know
smart I love you huh me how much TP do
you need those house are so funky you
know you need to hire a crew which is
[ __ ] those big lips there's a
shortage I'm this vandalizing what would
you do tp'ing and like all the fun that
I did for King is forking a king it's
fun this is real
you'd get plastic forks and you put them
in the lawn and so like the the four
part stuff like that in the line like
this and like you get those five yeah
that way so they're up and then you
litter somebody's along with it I used
to do 504 just sit there like a [ __ ]
rice planter yeah you go with her me and
my buddy
first of all were [ __ ] boosters
obviously that's creative yeah second of
all we all the girls that ever rejected
him we would fork your house oh my a lot
of girls rejected him but for me it was
just funny cuz it's like let's go
[ __ ] oh you were his sidekick yeah
but he was the inspiration I was just
like let's go [ __ ] doing funny why
not spoons it's just not it's funny when
you see little fork that's so funny you
guys should have cut off these two you
know there's like this you should've cut
these two that's a lot are you doing too
much no that's so much work imagine the
father who raised this this chick who
rejected my friend coming outside Forks
here if you had done that to [ __ ]
Bart's lawn you wouldn't give a [ __ ]
you'd be like laughs so we did what we
called the festival forks so yeah so we
did this intermittently to just random
chicks who dumped them right or didn't
like them but one night we hit a ball so
we went to all of their houses we bought
like [ __ ] 3,000 Forks from Costco oh
my god we put it in our yearbook at the
end of the year we put that was us we
put that that was us in the little thing
where the porker senior quote
[ __ ] you get to write whatever
you want at the end of it we had like
festival for mother for oh my
just drop for it just drop them yeah
every little calling card yeah she get a
tattoo of a fork so you can always
remember this day I might that might be
my first tattoo yeah we can't call you
guys my homework you're the fourth man
like hey you said that you you called
the iceman though that's a huge
admission
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]